good good so yeah we just uh
we just didn't record some interesting
things that's why
i always i almost always start recording
right away
because yeah it's probably better to do
it that way i was gonna oh well
we're already recording but what i
actually the thing that i wanted to talk
about off-camera we talked about on
camera and then just edited or something
uh was mostly uh like
i think that we should start to to to be
more deliberate about
some things like in terms of because i
see that there's so much crossover
between the bridges of meaning thing
and then the symbolic world thing and uh
and and i think that because of that it
would be a good idea to be a little more
deliberate about
kind of ways of collaborating and ways
of working together and building on what
each other
and what we're doing so that we're
actually building something
for that'll last that'll last or that
will produce fruit let's say so
i think that that's something that i'm
looking forward to next year that's when
i get settled into my house and
hopefully things are going to calm down
and
i'll have more time and energy to get
involved um
in that kind of stuff like i've visited
your me your bridge as a meaning
thing a few times and it kind of dropped
in i don't even know how discord worked
so i always
like i drop in on conversations and
people and then i don't even have my mic
on or something
yeah anyway so we'll figure it out no i
think that would be a good idea
i don't know exactly how um
the bridges of meaning thing so it was
members of my local meetup that started
that
and it has continued to evolve and it
continues to evolve
it's you know one of the things that i i
struggle with
is how we can use these platforms
for good but not be
overly innocent or naive about
the distortions that they bring into
patterns of relationships yeah and
you know we you know before we started
recording we were talking about
you know i'm glad i'm glad i'm doing
this
in my 50s because if i had done
something like this in my 20s and 30s
i'm really concerned about how
this would have formed me
because the the
the relational dynamics that you know
it's it's immensely flattering to have
the kind of
influence that one has where
people are listening to me for i mean
the people who listen to my youtube
channel
hear me far more than the people in my
local congregation
and they lack the
they they lack a bunch of the collateral
information that is normal in
face-to-face relationships
and i think what that means is that
there's distortion
in in sort of the relational
i don't even have the words for it yeah
no there is because
like you we talked about i guess we
we're gonna go back up
there is an aspect of the screen that
creates a celebrity weird celebrity
thing
and uh and you know i think it has to do
with the fact that you're watching
someone who doesn't see you
and also the fact i've talked about this
just the fact that
you're looking at a person that's
emanating light i think something is
as simple as that where you're standing
you're you have a frame like it's like a
it's like a speaking icon you have this
frame and you're looking at it and
it's talking to you and it's emanating
light and you and it doesn't see you
so i think that there's something about
that interaction which is
obviously dangerous because it it and
also because
because we're doing this on a screen
there's a frame and we can control that
frame to a certain extent right because
even in reality you can you can control
the frame
a little bit but on this it's much
easier like i can you don't know
anything about my private life like
it's just not a parent you don't see me
fight with my wife you don't see me
you know get being patient with my kids
which would be something that
in a normal relationship in a church or
in a community
you would be able to see my foibles and
all of my you know all my my darker side
not all of them but at least enough of
them so that
that the frame wouldn't have taken over
whereas now
i have to almost total control over what
you can see of me
you know and so it's a so it's a
dangerous way of interacting with people
yeah one of one of the things that we've
done
on the discord server lately is
we started it kind of has morphed into
what we're calling open studio and
in sense of an an art open studio and
that we're
we have our cameras on and
i in the discord server i've wanted to
at least to a degree
create a community where there are
cameras on because
i mean what we're doing that distortion
that you just talked about on youtube
is all over the internet because you
have an avatar
you have a false name you there's a
context-lessness and that that of course
creates the environment of trolling
where people drop in
you know unleash their payload and
evaporate out
and one of the things that you see in
real life communities before i got to
this church this church had a
bad history of destructive
congregational meetings
and part of that was people stand up in
a big room
unleash their anger frustration
and sit down and the community suffers
and so one of the things that we did
early on was if i knew we were going to
have a congregational meeting
to talk about hard things i would split
them up into groups of eight or ten
put chairs in a circle so if you had to
say a hard word you had to say it to
people's faces
and so if you said something painful you
would see the pain on
the face that you just delivered the
thing to
and and this i think is a big piece of
of overall the
the brutality that we see in our culture
that there's so much you know
if you're if you're going to be a human
being and you're going to hurt someone
you should have to live with the sight
of the pain that you
inflicted and so i don't know i
i i think about that in terms of okay so
what's my goal i
i mean i don't know maybe you've done
more reflecting on this i mean i
i backed into this thing and it's you
know don't get me wrong
it's been it's been fun it's been
some of the most fruitful ministry of my
life but
it is i i am concerned
i am concerned because of the ways that
it is
it is unreal in these respects
and it is it is ephemeral it just it can
it can just
float away unlike when you invest
in a real living community yeah
do you are you are you afraid also this
is the thing that has
bothered me or kind of preoccupied me is
the problem of it replacing also
yes normal normal community and so
people
don't end up joining a church or doing
them joining a community because it's
like they have this thing online that
they
that they get something from but it's
but that it's a kind of a pale version
of real community
yeah i think so i and so i've
you know over the i've watched brett and
eric weinstein
do their thing and the whole plan b idea
i mean
and this gets into the covid reset all
of these ideas that
okay we're going to remake the world now
and we're going to use these tools
and and and i watch them and i listen to
them and i think
number one i don't have a lot of stock
in
in your level of wisdom as to what the
world should be
that's right but also number two they
spend
no time that i can see
i mean again now both of us are
christians here so people
might roll their eyes a little bit at
this but the the whole point of tom
holland's book to me was that
jesus reset the world in a
in such a deep and profound way
that to me even in terms of
you know public knowledge it seems
really hard to argue against the fact
did that fact and and then
then i pause and ask okay
you know three years of public ministry
pouring himself into a dozen official
disciples one of whom betrays him
you know there's another group of 72 or
120 so there's
a small group of people and
and what jesus unleashes
you know begins to roll out of course to
the degree that
constantine for example you know adopts
under this banner he goes and
constantine doesn't quite understand
what he's doing
and and to me this okay you want to
change the world
why don't you look at what
i think is the man who changed the world
more than anyone
else and look at how he did it instead
of
running up youtube metrics
um political organizations i mean not to
say that those things don't have impact
but it seems to me
well if you really want to change the
world for the better and you've
and you actually embrace certain aspects
of this man's value
unwittingly and unconsciously and
continue to want to promote it
and maintain it in the world and
i don't know i don't know yeah there's
that it's interesting to understand that
the text from paul i forget in which
where it is i'm not good with the
with the the chapters and verses but he
talks about how
it's like at this very moment christ is
is dominating like he's ascending the
hierarchy and he's
he's uh subjugating principalities and
it's like it looks like he's talking
about a
a you know like a weird science fiction
thing that's happening in the background
like like
he's that he's doing these things like
almost like in a like in a i don't know
like
some japanese manga or something but
then you realize that it's
it was actually happening because 300
years later
the entire empire converts to
christianity so it's like
secretly in the background christ was
was was the fruits of what he did were
were increasing secretly and then
suddenly and all of a sudden it started
to show
and then finally you can see that the
world had been transformed
yeah and uh and actually understanding
that that's how reality works is
is super interesting because you can
also see it
you can even see how a weird you know
the weird flip that happened
in uh in culture let's say how like the
united states went secular and russia
became
christian like you can understand that
that you can understand that
change that way whereas each country was
secretly trying to influence the other
like you know america was sending bibles
to russia and like
sending secret missionaries to like go
encourage the church and russia was like
sending was sending you know distant
stuff to like
encourage radicalism and incurred
revolution and encourage
uh racial tension all this stuff was
being happening from the other side
and then in secret the seed grew and
then finally the two fruits appeared
and they would look like they had
switched places anyways it's just
interesting to think that that's how
actually reality works is that
there the fruits grow in secret first
and then finally
the it's not about changing this
changing systems doesn't
you need to change the hearts like
changing hearts is what would
what actually transforms reality it just
takes time it doesn't happen fast
well i i don't know you i mean your work
has
has really impacted me in this way
i mean part of what i've been you know i
did a video on
i don't quite have the i don't quite
have the language for
talking about what you're doing
i don't because what i
what i s you know the last couple of
days what i've been thinking about is
i i see cartesian dualism coming to an
end and i see
i think back on some of the previous
conversations that we've had and
and i think that's sort of the way your
work has been
colonizing me i mean the the second
conversation we had was about angels and
demons
and again i had the experience of
i wasn't quite sure what you were
talking about
but i i knew it was important
and and so what i've what i'm
what i'm seeing happen is that
this cartesian dualism of of sort of
a a of of imagining the world
as particles and
that this is going away and your more
pervasive paradigm as
sort of the sort of at least in the
imaginary the base
level of of experienced reality being
patterns that's
you know that's that's what's been
seeping into my head
and and so your conversation with
um with adam and rationality rules
i mean those those to me sort of
elicited the most dramatic
contrasts because it it made
it it made it exposed the fact that they
in a sense were building the world from
the ground up on
matter and you were asserting
that matter doesn't determine anything
matter is always colonized by something
yeah it's always it's it's always formed
by
by light it's always formed by logos it
has to
because or else it just it's just uh
it's just a sea of potentiality
and it's this is it's really like a
technical thing it's like
because underneath the world even in
scientific terms is it
whatever they call it quantum field or
whatever it's possible
possible uh positions of of
subatomic particles like that's what's
underneath everything and so it's not
even determined it's like it's a it's a
mush right it's like a
mush of indeterminacy and so and then
stacked up on that you have these
identities but
you know these identities are stack up
in terms of meaning they don't stack up
that's how they stack up they meaning is
that which forms the world and i think
the the greatest thing that's happening
right now and that's really the most
exciting thing
is i think we're in a place where people
can understand that
and it's hard and like you said it's
hard because you can see in those two
conversations i had especially the one
with rationality rules i think
it's it's like they they don't they
don't see it at all
it's like it's a blind spot and so you
try to point it out
and they're like they don't know what
you're talking about it almost kind of
just floats over
and then they want to come back to the
things that interest them uh
but then when you when you assert cert
these this type of reality it just kind
of it's weird it kind of just floats by
and and you see that and i think this is
the thing that i saw
even with with someone like brett
weinstein or other other
other characters in these types of
discussions is that
they if you try to point out how reality
works
they it's like i don't know it's hard to
understand why people can't
i don't understand anywhere why people
can't see it because i've been seeing
the world this way for 20 years
but i i encounter people who tell me
like you said
like you said before i didn't know what
you were talking about and then in one
day or
slowly it started to click and then it's
then i started to see oh this is
he he this is what he's talking this is
what he's talking about right
um so so i think that if there's one
thing that i'm that i'm doing
i hope that that's it like i hope it's
to help people
understand the inevitability of meaning
and the inevitability of and that this
is what scripture is talking about
like the description in genesis is a
description of a
of an ontological hierarchy right it's
more that than
anything else it's a description of how
there are analogies of
above of light meaning breath all of
these
these things that that that are talked
about in the first chapter
and then there are analogies of below
the darkness unformedness chaos
emptiness
uh water like all these images and and
it's it's just like a massive
putting all these analogies together to
try to help you understand how
how the world exists and still exists
now it's
the world exists the same way that it's
described in
in in the in the first chapter of
genesis it the
manifestation happens in the same way as
what's described in that in that in that
book you know it's still light meaning
logos
uh that comes from above and that which
calls forth uh you know from the earth
forms and also there's a there's even in
creation
so there's a kind of freedom there
because god says
let the earth produce and so it's like
god is giving a main
category it's like let god let the earth
produce
uh uh you know plants that produce seed
of their own of their own kind and so
god is giving the meaning and using the
seed thing it's like
let let's produce plants that have the
same identity a continuous identity and
we'll continue on with that identity
and then after that there's all this
variety which kind of comes up and that
variety
it's almost like god didn't have to say
all the different names of all the
different plants
he just like there's the main category
which comes down and then there's this
filling up
i use the example i don't know i forget
which part of i think i did use that
example in the rationality rules
discussion or maybe it's not the one
that was recorded where i say
you know god says let there be cars and
then
audi and all the companies start
producing all these different varieties
of cars
you don't need to from above like you
can have like
larger larger categories right and then
they they kind of scale down and start
to to
disseminate into the world so it's like
that's how reality works
like even now god is the world's still
being created that way
well yeah and you can see that in
markets that
you know once once you know let's say
the computer
manifest there was compact and ibm and
hp
and you know hundreds of little places
where
computers were manifesting all over the
place and
let there be computers and and suddenly
there were there were computers all over
the place
yeah and there's the and then there's
this like uh i forget which
term john uses but john has all these
great terms to talk about
this this system of how the
there's a there's like an exchange
between the identity and the
multiplicity
and there's this this kind of breathing
in and breathing out you know where
where there's a pushing and pulling and
then that's how
the the so it's not a static reality
it's a dynamic relationship between
identities and
and their potential and so it's like it
just moves back and forth you know
uh and it and it ends up being like a
like the breathing in and breathing out
of
of of reality so
and so i think that that's like if i can
get help people understand that
and also understand that if someone
asked me something
like you believe that that the genesis
creation account happened it's like
not only do i believe it happen i
believe it's happening now it's it's
always happening it's the most
happening it's the most it's the best
description of reality that has ever
been written down
so it's like i not only do i not want to
discount it it's like
i i base my entire world on it
everything that i think
is based on that account and and i feel
no no qualms or shame about saying that
and i don't
feel like i like it's a stretch of my
imagination i don't have to push my
imagination anywhere it's
it's uh it's that's how reality really
really really works
but i i think if you
because it's i really liked your
conversation with guy
and i know i know you know you might
have felt oh this is
too much talking about me but i i think
i think it's really in in a sense people
have to
sort of walk with you through your story
to get to where you are now because
if you look in a tribal frame from what
you just said of genesis
a whole group of people in christianity
and certain segments of christianity
would say oh i'm so glad to hear
jonathan say that but they still have
absolutely no idea what you're talking
about
because they are because they are
they are materialists and the
entire conversation i mean the western
church
the western church ripped itself open
over this question about how
material is genesis 1
and and you know so john walton who
taught old testament at wheaton college
and has written some books
the lost world of genesis one this lost
world series
he i mean even when he in the
evangelical space
starts talking about the fact that
this really isn't about materiality
that you know certain parts of the
evangelical world hear that
and get nervous and but then
the other side of it so you have the
fundamentalist modernists the other side
of it sort of cheer
but for the wrong reasons exactly
no you're right i totally agree yeah and
and so i think it's i think it's
important
you know i think what you're doing is
vitally important
because you can't take this thing
on directly because you know it
one of the most interesting moments of
the gospels that always shocks me
is so jesus is heading down to jerusalem
with his disciples
and he says okay this is what's going to
happen
we're going to go down to jerusalem
first they're they're really nervous
about going down to jerusalem for
real reasons and we're going to go down
to jerusalem
i'm going to be turned over into the
hands of gentiles i'm going to be
crucified and
three days later i'll rise again they
didn't seem to hear
anything about the rising again they did
not register
and the only thing they heard was the
political layer of this
that i am going to be i am going to the
the gentiles are going to have me in
their hands and they're going to have
their way with me
and of course peter stands up and says
i'll never let this happen
and get behind me satan and i think
that's
i think that's an instructive
that's an instructive lesson in how
people change
and even even the entire
so when i was in college you know so i
grew up i grew up a
minister's kid you go to way to college
i went to a christian college but
calvin college sort of had the theme of
we're not going to be your parent if you
want to drink and
if you want to if you want to rebel you
go ahead it's it's crc rum spring
so if you want to rebel go ahead and do
that and so i start reading
start kind of thinking okay do i want to
be a christian so i start reading the
gospels
and i was immediately frustrated by the
gospels because
they didn't seem to be talking to
anything in my life
but now the longer that i think about it
jesus through those stories
was reprogramming the world and of
course
even even the story layer doesn't quite
hit all the layers down and so what was
even more clear
was that even though the disciples
didn't understand jesus
at all he was reprogramming them
yeah and and so then that gets me to the
question
okay what happened in pentecost because
in my old frame of let's say cartesian
dual substances there's a material
substance and a spiritual
substance but basically through your
work
i'm seeing that as not a helpful way to
imagine
the spiritual world yeah i think that i
think that
what happened in pentecost is what
happened at the beginning of genesis
like in the creation of adam
so basically what you have is something
like
christ came and then gathered a body
together
and also gave them all the information
and so he gave them all this information
and then they gathered and they gathered
but
they didn't have yet what it took to
to be alive and and then pentecost is
the moment in genesis where god blows
air into adam's nostrils and and makes
all those disparate elements come
together and so you can understand it as
a
in my discussion with guy seng talk i
talk a little bit about my experience of
that where
it's like i grew up in a more kind of
evangelical background where we had all
the bible stories but i
i didn't i never felt like you said that
there was any
that it was almost like arbitrary it was
like here's this story which is true but
it but it has an arbitrariness to it and
so there are all these stories from
all the from the and they try to really
try it hard to find morality tales and
these old testament stories because
they're really hard to
if you see them that way man you're
going to struggle because a lot of those
old testament stories are very little
uh morality tale to them uh but so all
these stories are there
and then when something happens at some
point where it's like
the curtain opens up and then all of
this information all of this
this conglomeration of things joins
together and becomes a body
so i think that that's what happened at
pentecost it's it's like
they received the holy spirit the the
the the breath of god blew down
and they became an actual body
which and and that included several
things it included
that they cohered together uh it
included
that they stopped being afraid right
because they they had confidence they
had they trusted
in what why they were together uh and so
the
all the elements of what makes something
one kind of
came down upon them and so you know and
so
so peter stood up in a kind of
leadership position
and and then then because they had this
kind of coherence they also
but at pentecost the thing about
pentecost is that it's both a coherence
and a kind of wild multiplicity goes all
it like fills up everything because it
it both has them coming together
understanding what
this was all about from the beginning
you know cohering as a group
but then having the capacity to reach
the
end of the world like going and speaking
in a way that can be understood by
anybody who is there to understand right
uh tonga fire right the idea that they
can speak
they can speak multi into multiplicity
and so it really is like this cosmic
event
where like you said it's the the program
the reprogramming that christ was doing
started to bear fruit in this body that
he had accumulated
and then it started to grow and it
started to it started to
lay itself out you know in in in time
and it and and the way it laid itself
out was people imitating christ
and understanding that the martyrs are
the seeds of the church
and this is like an actual reality that
if if people who die
for who die like people who who would
end up dying
for christ would create little
seeds that would go in and then bodies
would accumulate around those seeds
and then the church just started to grow
and to grow and to transform
to transform reality both in terms of
ideas but
but even physically like geographically
the geography of
of the world changed as the
christianization happened
like cities started to manifest around
uh martyrdom sites
and and all of the whole political
sphere started to
be transformed as these new sacred
spaces
were being installed you know and then
constantinople was the biggest deal of
that where
you know people always say rome fell
it's like rome fell because
constantinople
grows in glory too it's not just it's
not just that rome fell
is that this this new city this
christian city would never
which never had a pagan temple uh became
the new center of the world
so so i think that that's the that's
that's it like
pentecost is such a wonderful image of
of how reality works it just shows you
it's it's a real
instantiation of a new creation you
could say it that way
well it's well that leads so many
interesting places because
i mean this continues to happen in
christianity
in in that i mean the center of mass
the people do these weird masks about
the center of mass of christianity and
unlike
islam and a number of other major ruled
world religions that they they
basically continue to have sort of where
their center
is is where their center always has been
christianity
it just moves around the globe and
i mean in africa and in asia
and in latin america although latin
america is a very interesting story
because of the roman catholic and then
the evangelicals but um
i so so having said that to come back to
to what we mentioned first
what is happening right now
through the symbolic world
and through bridges of meaning discord
and through youtube
i think i i
you know i don't know
did you think your channel would get
this large
i don't think that way like i just don't
i don't plan
that way my life my whole life is not is
never
in that sense i just kind of do the
things that are there
uh and try to do them fully and that's
that's usually the way that i i
approach things so to me what i see
let's say what i hope i can tell you
what i hope out of this
is i kind of
i think that this i the way i talked
about this before with
with a few people which is that this is
the future like
the the the symbolic world view whether
you
you frame it exactly the way that i'm
framing it or that or whether you frame
it
you know in terms of the way that john
vervicky frames it in terms of cognitive
science or if you frame it the way that
ian
gilchrist frames it in terms of you know
you know the
the right right hemisphere kind of
global vision
all of this is the is the future and i
think a lot of people are
realizing it right and so
what i but it's also the thing is that
it's also one of the things that brought
bringing
that are that is bringing about some of
the madness around us
the fact that symbolism is coming back
into
into the world and manifesting strongly
is is one of the things that is also
causing the craziness
of the frame shift in media for example
and so one of the things that people are
understanding is how
framing information is more important
than information and everybody now is
seeing
that right because of because of the way
that even just the way your
your election happened was crazy like
the things that they
that they decided to report on and the
things they didn't decide to report on
and the way that they frame the the
what's happening
is more important than any information
that's there so everybody's seeing that
and some people are taking advantage of
it
and then creating very weird ideological
clicks and
creating weird new social rituals and
you know even a lot of the covet stuff
has a weird relate uh
religious tone to it you know in terms
of also the
the the blm protests and all of that had
a lot of religious
overtones to it so this is it like
you're not going to stop this
and although the new atheists can whine
all they want they're not going to stop
it it's
religion's coming back it's coming back
and now the question is
how is it going to come back you can't
stop it and so
what what i hope is that in speaking
into this kind of frenetic
transformation that's going
on that that that we can help
create stable places or stable people
people that
have enough vision and enough
centeredness
that they can act as seeds in their own
communities
that they can go back into their church
and help their church prevent from going
crazy
because it's it's gonna get worse it's
gonna just keep getting worse
and so be part of the people that are
helping their churches just
to not go crazy that they they can go
back and it doesn't necessarily have to
be a church but in their communities
helping them prevent the the madness
that's going on
by having a balanced vision of this
heaven and earth
hierarchy in all its aspects both the
negative and positive understanding
you know the role of the margin
understanding the role of the center
and then seeing all of this as this as
the necessary
part of the cosmos and so that's what i
hope and
and i don't know if it's going to i
don't want it i definitely don't want it
to become this weird kind of
inner discussion too much where we're
all talking amongst ourselves and we're
all
kind of happy that we understand things
you know and and
and winking at each other because we can
see that other people don't get it
that that's not what i don't want to be
that's not what happens you know i
really
i really hope that it's going to produce
fruits into
in uh in the world which is why like
which is why if you
on the symbolic world we started a blog
and uh
i wanted people to kind of train
themselves to write
on symbolism and and uh you know i'm
gonna start to
probably appear on some of the youtube
channels of the different people on the
symbolic world
uh facebook group just to kind of help
people train them
to get a little army of symbolic
thinkers
that that can then go into their own
domains and
and start to have fruit you know that's
what i hope and at least
at least that that's what i that's
that's would be the
if you could boil down what i'm doing to
one thing i think that's probably
probably it well i think your i think
your emphasis
on on community
and on in real life community
is is vital
no i i i think that's right and part of
what i see
i i had the thought a couple of days ago
that i wonder if
say the period from the last five
hundred years as charles tarellos talks
about i wonder if
200 years from now that will be looked
back upon as a dark age
and find the find the um embracing of
the world
the word enlightenment to be horribly
ironic
i think so i definitely think so
and and i think you know as a
i think a lot of churches i mean this is
i mean what you're describing is
happening in churches
because the i mean my own little church
the this this certain way of the certain
way of doing churches
dying that has been the dominant
paradigm in
in protestantism at least i mean the
catholics have
always kind of gone through their own
transformations
and of course the orthodox are are
coming online in north america in a
i think in a growing way but
the
how this how then the church
how this changes church for people
i think will be profound and
i i don't know what it looks like i
really don't know what it looks like
i i i understand that
i think it's the one thing it's not
going to look like
and i hope and i don't think it's
possible and i don't even want that is
that one thing it's not going to look
like
is a bunch of people like for that in my
case like a bunch of people who
understand these things
because that's not that's not
understanding for example symbolism is
really not
that important like it's important now
because we're in a weird upside down
kind of end of civilizations period but
in normal normal world you don't need to
understand it you have to enact it you
just have to
be inside and enact it and so so what i
what i'm hoping is that the people that
are kind of
influenced by by what's going on these
discussions about meaning and everything
can then go back in their world and then
produce other things not symbolic
discussion but
rather you know help people live the
liturgy better
help people live the the you know
help people see the value of their
stories you know and then also
create new versions of old stories and
and uh
and get people involved in that and so
to me that's the
that'll be the the key you know and also
just the excitement the excitement about
scripture and the excitement the the the
feeling
also like the sense of confidence about
how true this is you know in a different
way
than what the materialists have said
which is kind of crumbling and
always fraught i think that that that's
going to be
that can be infectious as well because
and i've seen it like i've talked to
some
of the old pastors that i grew up with
who are kind of very materialist and and
if i talk about it in the right way
if they see in my eyes that i love the
bible
that i really love scripture and that
it's like i am so excited about
scripture and about
all the potential all the stuff in there
that you haven't totally seen yet
and then like and i'm talking about the
relationship between you know the garden
and the temple and
and i'm showing them the pattern how it
how it you know like let's say like
how i laid out pentecost for you just
before like i've noticed that that gets
people excited
you pastors who who have been studying
scripture for a very long time they
don't feel threatened by it if you
present it in the right way and so it's
like that that type of excitement and
uh i think that that that can be
that can be wildfire you know and then
it can be transmitted
and but it's not necessarily going to
happen in a in an
explanation of what these things mean in
the end
participation well and i think that's
part part of the you know part of the
deception
that's happening on these screens and in
these little frames on smartphones and
computer monitors and televisions
i i think is that through this
medium we can only we can only do
certain things and one of those things
are conversations about symbolism or
we can only do certain things in this
little frame and the real frame
that things have to happen in are
the the incarnational frame
of okay what does it mean to be
uh faithful to your wife and to build a
community
and to um to to actually have
logos shape and colonize
and and reform all the materiality
around us and and i think this is part
of the reason
that it's critical that you're an artist
because even though well maybe now
you're sort of well known
as someone who explains rudolph and
vampires
yeah um the you know what
what you're i mean iconography
is is is
iconographic itself
and that's you know that's i'm okay i've
come from an iconoclastic
tradition and so you know this is
there's a little bit of this
dissonance involved in this for me but
it's
the it's the practice of
the the church i mean leslie knew again
had this had this great quote the um
the church is the hermeneutic of the
gospel
yeah in in that
okay what why did um
why was jesus able to conquer the roman
empire in 300 years through
his spirit because the holy spirit is
the spirit of christ
it's also the spirit of the creator i
mean it's that's why you have a trinity
and how was jesus able to conquer the
roman empire
in 300 years and the answer is
the his pattern
because no one of us can fully manifest
the the full pattern of christ
but the pattern of christ gets
manifested
in these communities and in their life
and
in what they do and always you know
always in a limited way
always but but yet sufficiently so
that it it literally toppled the empire
and that entire way of life and and
again that's what
that's what tom holland has been
documenting
that christ conquered the empire
yeah definitely and it's wonderful to
have that book it's such a great it's
such a gift i really
i was reading it while i was cheering
and i while i was carving and i was
cheering in some of the places like i
was like yes
i can't believe i'm so happy that he's
saying this and he's saying it so well
way better than i could ever say it so
so yeah
i totally agree in terms of of the the
embodiment and it's it's really like for
me it's a lesson i need to make sure
that i say that because i it's like i
you know i have if people who follow me
carefully have seen that i've talked
about my
own alienation towards kind of french
canadians and their
um and their rejection of christianity
and so it's like i'm also i also
know like i know and i feel it in front
of me like i feel it in front of me that
i
need to be involved like
physically bod embodied involvement
in this this this place where i am
i need to be more involved because or
else my soul and
my body and spirit are going to start to
split apart because here i am saying
these things online
but i'm also have this thing that i need
to heal in my life where i need to
to now kind of dive in and be and be
like a
french canadian person in this society
that is that is
acting and and and being involved so so
it's like i
this is like the next step for me and i
know that it's it's coming because
next year this is going to be next year
especially because we won't be able to
travel anyway so it's like
all of god is putting it's like this is
in front of me this is
it jonathan no more like uh you need to
you need to live
by what you say
that's that that's true that's true it
also strikes me
as i mean part of what's happening
in the world via this technology and the
internet
is that i mean it's there's always kind
of a both sides
and i've been thinking about empire and
what
oh i mean we we we're near we nearly
have a one
world culture in some ways because of
the internet
and so and that is corrosive
you know i so the french canadian the
french canadian-ism
that came about because of the you know
because of the way
the way that the waves happen in north
america by different european countries
that created something and and part of
what
the internet is doing is sort of you
know
reducing all texture in the world
and yeah and and but it's but there's
always this tension
there's always this tension in
an evangelism that
you know it's the one in the many and i
think again your your
your symbolic vision has been really
helpful for me
to kind of manifest that that
there was always something at the heart
of protestantism which was an
a which was an unhelpful uniformity
that by virtue of
the let the earth bring forth let the
seas bring
forth there's a healthy diversity and a
multiplicity in that
that that god affords and that christ
affords
but that a certain protestant vision
of the world tends to
yeah but i think it's more i think it's
a western thing because it happened
it happened also it wasn't just
protestantism like if you look at the
way that the latin
church uh enforced itself on
on england for example and how latin was
enforced in in the celtic lands you can
see that there's a strange thing that
happened in the west that even in
catholicism
and then in the counter reformation the
council of trent was like this
massive like uniformization of the
of the liturgy uniformization of of the
you know of latin kind of just going all
the way into
to to anywhere that catholicism was so
there's something about the west which
has this desire to create
uniform systems um and then which
obviously then goes into everything else
like in terms of
in terms of in terms of how we view
government and how
you know you can look at the way that
the different ref
the different revolutions happen and how
there was this desire to
to kind of you make education uniform
make language
everybody's before napoleon not no one
spoke french in france
like this french idea came from napoleon
just enforced
one version of french on the entire on
the entire country but before that it
was all
local dialects and local languages so
there's something about
western culture which has which which
does that uh
you know and i don't know like people
will trace it to to
to whatever they want to but it's it's
not i don't think this is necessarily a
protestant thing
in the orthodox tradition it's like a
weird
tension right it has its positive and
its negatives
like it has a it has a positive because
they tend to translate like they'll
translate
right away when they converted the
russians they translated everything into
they actually created
the slavonic language and then they
translated everything into slavonic
uh you know they created a written
version of the language that was spoken
there
and so then they developed their own
thing i guess and that kind of happened
all over the place
but in protestantism that's part the
parasitism has the two extremes because
it also has the extreme variety
like radical variety where the
translating of the bible in every single
tribal dialect that you can imagine
you know it's like a goal and then you
have all these
all these idiosyncratic versions of of
christianity all over the place of the
world so it's like
it's like a i think the west has like
the radical the two radical sides of
like
total enforcement and then just like
this brief role
i guess something like that i would i
was yesterday on the
so we have this little open studio and
and sally jo came in she's an
artist and she she came in and she said
i tried to have a conversation with a
protestant about
art in church and
and i i almost wanted to hide under the
desk because
i i knew exactly where this was going
because this this gets into this
question
of the one and the many because it gets
into this
this question of when you start
when you when you start instantiating a
vision
in in visual media
there's a power there that
in some ways preachers kind of get to
sidestep
by keeping everything verbal yeah
and you know when i i mentioned that
when i went down to nicaragua i went
down to nicaragua during the sandinista
revolution
and more radical college days and
there was you know they had these
revolutionary churches
where you had sandinista rebels
hanging on crosses uh nude with these
huge phalluses
and i mean it's
i i i'd really you know and when sally
joe was talking to me about
okay so you know if you had okay so a
how do you represent now we're in the um
we're in the season of advent now
heading towards christmas
how do you represent the story of mary
and joseph
visually and you know and to me
it's a big deal like even in the
orthodox tradition like that's a big
deal
well that's why i said you got to talk
to pejo because
you know immediately when you raise this
it is a huge deal and when i look at
your story
yeah i mean that that's why i don't
think you should be too bashful about
your story because
this you yourself were the
matter in which all of these stories
came down and and manifest themselves
and this
and this struggle of you know sally joke
said quite rightly she said
you know all these protestants are
resisting are resisting the visual arts
but they still have to do architecture
and so they're still
manifesting in their architecture in
their liturgy
and their music in all of these ways
they're still
manifesting culture they just sort of
have a willful she didn't quite say it
this way but
they have the sort of willful blindness
about it that if we
construct our campus to look like a
junior college
we can sidestep the question of if we're
going to have
mary and joseph rolling into cleveland
in
a in a 96 honda because
once you once you locate mary and joseph
in a visual art medium you have
questions of race
of class of of nationality
you know we have all of these layers
that get manifest in a visual medium
and and when i look at what you've done
you've said basically okay i'm going to
go to
the traditional and and you know when i
remember your story
that's a big deal for you because what
was happening
in other ways is that people were you
know
okay we're going to put san anisto
rebels up on a cross
and i mean so i'm really curious about
what to do with this because yeah this
is at the heart of what we're
struggling with you have to so you have
to kind of see it as
if you see the tradition as
as this kind of organic living thing
that that almost like you can almost use
weird evolutionary terms like
to talk about it where it's like there
are propositions
and and there there are propositions and
then some are
kept and some are discarded so there's a
there's a
system of weeding and weeding in weeding
out that happens and then sometimes
someone proposes something which is a
little too radical and then
maybe like a church council or a local
council
has to kind of smack it down right uh
and and then another someone produces
something which is actually
extremely powerful and then maybe the
authorities will
nudge people in that direction and will
say like there's a for example like
the russian church one one time said you
should make images like uh
like now is my my his his name is not
gonna come to me
uh like rublev you should make images
like rublev and so they actually named
an artist and said
you should make images that copy his his
style uh
and and so what happens is because it's
like a theological process
then what ends up being kept
ends up being extremely theological
because there's like this organic
process of weeding
in and weeding out you know uh and then
some and so then when you want to
propose something different you always
have to
look and try to understand why is it
this way
why why do we show things this way
rather than another
way because it's like the whole idea of
like not removing fences like even if
you don't
understand why it's that way you should
probably respect it because
a lot of energy and a lot of uh you know
a lot of energy went into it by a lot of
people it's not just
someone who someone probably did come up
with it but then the fact that it was
preserved and that it was slightly
modified through time then it ends up
being so i think that that's a good way
to understand why
traditional images have the power they
do and why
they're really a good starting ground to
understand
how to represent things visually and so
like for example in terms of mary and
joseph a good
a good thing that you would you will
notice if you look at orthodox icons is
that
they'll never show mary and joseph uh
like a couple
like you know those images of the holy
family that's not orthodox like orthodox
orthodox that when you see every time
you'll see an orthodox person maybe
making one of those
you'll get a bunch of a bunch of angry
comments like people
are not happy about showing joseph's arm
around mary
and like so you have joseph's arm around
mary and then you have baby jesus in her
in her arms and so it's like if you
understand what images do like images
suggest meanings like they they're not
arbitrary right so
if you suggest a sexual relationship
between joseph and mary you're actually
calling into question
the virgin birth like ultimately you're
calling that into question
and so like the the image of the image
of nativity is actually pretty
scary for some people because the
nativity icon shows joseph
outside the cave like
wondering what's going on like not
understanding what's happening
and mary is is inside the cave alone
and she was helped by you know by uh
by uh what's the name of by women like
there's women who helped her give birth
it's not joseph like
there's no way in the world that in 2000
years ago a husband would help
his wife or a man would help his wife
give birth such a modern thing
to think about that and so but there's a
reason why they do that because they
really
want to avoid anybody thinking that
joseph is the father of jesus
in every way like you can't have
anything suggesting that
and so it's it's a theological decision
and
it can it can offend our sensibilities
because we want
to show the family right right but
there's something higher that is more
important than just showing a nice
happy family right which is this idea
that christ
is the son of god
i i i laugh because i
google google's getting off of google
music and so now i'm playing around with
youtube music and
just yesterday i was thinking okay i'm
just gonna i'm just gonna search for
uh christian popular christian
christmas music 2020. and
you know there's all these again what
struck me was there's
all you know a lot of this is
evangelical music and so many of these
attempts
are okay let's let's show let's show
joseph and mary and jesus as the
dare i use the word iconic nuclear
family
yeah that's the way people want to
present it but it's a it's a it's a bad
move
it's a really bad move i think
theologically to do that
there are find other there are other
families that you can find
to to do that i guess but it's not it's
not it's not a good move
[Laughter]
jonathan no no no you don't have to
apologize but to me
it's it's symbolism happens and
you know part of part of what i struggle
with is
say looking at the orthodox
looking at orthodox representations
i wonder i mean our first conversation
you asked me how was your liturgy and i
told you it was a mess
and i still hold to my answer because it
continues to be a mess
but but part of what part of why it
continues to be a mess
is that i have i have lived
such a such a multicultural life
so my on my father's side my
ancestors were jews who probably left
spain uh found you know fled to the
netherlands which was sort of a place of
tolerance
um you know one of the one of the guys
on our discord server is a
um was a was an ultra-orthodox jew and
he did some genealogy i shared some
genealogy says
well you've got a bunch of distant
relatives who are prominent rabbis in
israel and it's like that's hilarious
and so i you know then
you know a number of generations back
my great-great-great-grandfather start
marrying dutch girls
and my great-great-grandfather sends
my great grandfather to america to
western michigan to assimilate with the
dutch
and my grandfather becomes a minister
and my father becomes a pastor in a
black community
and i work in the dominican republic and
then come to this multi-everything
community
in sacramento in a dutch
calvinist religious tradition
in the world the world is such a blender
and and i think part of
all of these all of these strains do not
disappear
and so the question then becomes
how how do all of these patterns
find a degree of harmony in
christ that blesses the world
you know and i see some of you know i i
don't know
obviously your life to the same
resolution that i don't mind but
young man raised in an evangelical
context obviously i mean you spoke with
guy about
your father and and the ways that you've
spoken about him before
you know a a a good man and a christian
man
you you go on this your own journey
of exploration and wind up
you know you spend some time in congo
you wind up
you know now in
in orthodoxy but
part of what i you know when i talked to
i talked to a guy in my
my channel burn power who is an american
who grew up jesus people
in california then moved to new york
city so he could be in the music and art
scene
and then moved to alaska and now is
living in tbilisi georgia
and so i asked him about orthodoxy there
and he talked about because
um george is one of the you know a
deeply orthodox country
and so i talked to him about some of
these issues
and orthodoxy in america
is going to be a different thing and
part of what happens in america is there
sort of
a there's sort of a ghetto phase and
maybe the french canadian
is kind of a a really large ghetto
my only experience there i visited i've
visited montreal once when i was young
and we were at some sort of an amusement
park and
and i was in line for some rides and
some french-speaking kids
didn't treat me real well so there's
there's what's back in my lair
yeah but but what i see happening in
terms of these
these dual tensions of globalization
which sort of
sort of reduces individuality
into this broad consumer culture yet
the the contextual the textuality
of every different place and every
different story
i'm i'm deeply interested in
in in what the orthodox church is going
to
look like in this context because it
will be
very different from what you find in
tablesi georgia
yeah for sure and i think that's
inevitable um
the orthodoxy definitely in america has
a protestant flavor especially
the convert type orthodox that's just it
just happens
you know it's it's hard to avoid that um
and that can actually have some positive
elements
you know because the rigidity let's say
of systems like like in any system
can be a danger for a a highly
hierarchical
system like orthodoxy it can be a it can
be a problem and and that's
i think some of the things that led to
the revolution were the problems
inherent in
in these types of of the structures
you know where you have corrupt
individuals who nonetheless
remain in power and then you know use
the church to their own
and then all the kind of stuff that led
to the reformation too you know that
the stuff that led to the reformation
was real like there really were
all these problems i i don't want to
even though i i tend to not side on the
side of the reformation i
i can recognize the reasons why people
were angry
you know and so i think in america
there's a fascinating thing where
the kind of protestant flavor it it it
gives
an energy which is really good you know
and it gives
also a uh a love of scripture
and a desire to be it's a desire to not
take things lightly
like to not take the way that
protestants are like serious protestants
don't take scripture lightly you see the
same with people
who who are orthodox in america where
it's like they don't take the co
they don't take liturgy lightly they
don't take the the church fathers
lightly they tend to to really want to
get down
to the bottom and not just gloss over
things um
and i think that that that can be that
can be useful
sometimes it creates a kind of rigorous
weird rigorism
that is there too in america in the in
the
certain orthodox convert groups where
they're extremely rigorous
like super super rigorous and you know
it's like they they know all the cannons
of all the councils and they know all
the
all the things and they're they're
they're extremely they try to be very
very
rigorous which which in my opinion is
not it's not the best way to go
but you know you need a bit of that too
because or else it just everything gets
floppy but so it is fascinating to watch
and it's also very
it's in the image of america it's a
weird multicultural multiple
and it's it's actually not how orthodoxy
shouldn't have
all these different churches right so
it's like
you know in in in greece there's a greek
there's the orthodox church and
there's the bishop and there are priests
and there's the archbishop and whereas
in america there's like the there's the
there's the oca there's the russian uh
rokkor church there's the antioch in
church
there's the greek church there's the
ukrainian church and so
romanian church so it's like it's it's
actually a weird
it's actually a weird a freaky thing
where you have all these
competing and parallel hierarchies kind
of
uh working together which is maybe in
the image of america
uh makes it even more in the image of
america so
and people can just like it's weird
because like a lot of people
a lot of people like they leave
protestantism to become orthodox because
they're like oh finally like i'm gonna
be
i'm gonna find the thing but then within
orthodoxy they keep
switching churches they keep going
they'll go to the greeks then the
russians then
this and so they're still we're like
they're still acting like protestants
within orthodoxy because there's that
capacity to like move
from one hierarchy to the other if the
one the one you're in doesn't suit you
for some reason or whatever
right it's almost it
we won't know we've done something until
we actually exercise
this consumerist spirit that
leaves the consumer at the heart
you know that because that in many ways
that i mean that's a deep
problem in protestant churches as well
which has i've seen that
grow in the christian reformed church 50
75 years ago
you were a member of a church pastors
kind of came and went
but the church was the community
they they invested they held they
cared and pastors sort of were role
players
yeah and in america you know the
celebrity pastor
is the heart and then the people act
like consumers
which means that there's no actual
community yeah and there's
there's also like the service church you
know where it's like i go to that church
because it has a good youth group it has
a good this it has
you know it's like you you look at the
menu that the church offers
and then you you see oh well the church
has this this this this and so
it's like i'll go there because it has
this it has
you know it it has the options that i
like
you know and so that's obviously that's
seriously
a difficult it's it's so hard to break
free from that because we're so used to
it
it's almost so it's ingrained in us to
see ourselves as
as consumers that it's it's hard
well it's a manifestation of what's at
the center right that's right
all right these are at the center and
and
church and god and the world
are you know here to serve me
it's so completely opposite the heart of
the gospel yeah
well to swing back then again to the
symbolic world bridges of meaning
these channels because
well and because you know when you ask
that question i mean part of
and i was i started making videos partly
because
i watched i watched jordan
basically cut a hole through the fabric
you know maybe that wasn't the right
image maybe i saw him create
huge ripples in the pond yeah and i
watched um you know someone recently
had a tweet where they said you know
first i listened to sam harris then i
listened to jordan peterson
then verveiki and pajeo and vander clay
and
now i'm thinking about being a christian
i blame sam harris
that's right does the layers i love that
tweet that's so funny and it's just
it's like i've heard i mean i'm sure
it's the same with you i've gotten so
many
messages of people that have that story
very similar yeah
but then but then the question is part
of the reason i started making videos
was
as a pastor i knew that jordan's sort of
moving through the zeitgeist as a
televangelist
with his books and his videos people um
you know disturbing people they're
having new insights
and then they start looking around for
you know all very intuitively
where can i keep going and i knew that
when you when you do this to people okay
let's say you let's use jesus parable if
you clean the house
if you don't fill it with something
that vacuum you know will attract other
things
into the house and so part of why i got
into this
was i knew that a vacuum was being
created
and i you know i didn't know to what
degree i could help
but i wanted to at least give people
something
okay you're interested in the bible
here's you know
let's let's keep talking about this
because you the bible can go a lot of
weird ways as protestants yeah
generally and not just that but it's
like you can see it like you've you've
seen the
you've seen the moments you've seen the
moments of like douglas murray saying
this would be a good time to make up a
new religion
you can see brett weinstein talking
about creating
and we talked about this with adam
friended this wanting to create like a
superstructure that would manage all the
other
structures and so there is this this
desire
in this void to say well we're going to
build the tower
and uh you know it's going to it's going
to reach heaven and so
it's a it's actually you're right in a
way it is a dangerous time
you know especially even the psychedelic
stuff also you can see that it's like
we're gonna fill this void with
psychedelics or some weird version of
like
a new religion with psychedelics or
something um
and aliens and alien aliens
interdimensional beings fall right
and so and so i think that i think that
you're right i think that
we that we it's our responsibility and
it's our
we have to if we had this weird
opportunity that was you kind of almost
thrust upon us to kind of talk into
it and to hopefully be a little nudge
of people to go back into the story that
we're still in like we're still in this
story it's not
the story isn't gone or at the we might
be
you know towards the fringe of it but
it's still the story so
well and and and that leads me into you
know your question
i mean two things have sort of developed
around us i look at the symbolic world
and you've got a blog i really love jp
marceau's
follow up on the miracles conversation
that i had with verveiki
and and the lewis conversation but the
you know some some people out there say
well you need to
you know paul you're you're starting a
new church and it's like
no that is not what i want to start um
and and i i really appreciate the fact
that you're orthodox for that reason
because
you're in that way even further from the
protestant
impulse of every new ripple in the pond
starts a new denomination
and which which there's a there's
something
which is deeply problematic about that
so but there's something about the fact
that you i think the fact that you
you follow louis i think that that's one
of the effects that lewis has had
uh is to point people back to
their christian roots without starting a
new thing without saying like i'm gonna
start a new movement or a new church or
a new
a new denomination um and so i think the
fact that you place yourself
kind of firmly in lewis's footsteps
i think that's a good sign like it's a
good sign that that you're you're not
trying to start a new
like a new protestant denomination but
rather
just help people move through their own
struggles and their own crisis
their own meaning crisis so that they
then go back in their communities
you know get involved how
how serious i mean part of what tom
holland impressed upon
me is the
you know my denomination
and well and orthodoxy too i mean
there's a strong
antithesis element to christianity where
you're in or you're out and that's
you know that's that that is not going
away
but part of what tom holland's work
talks about
is the latent
the latent christianity
even in celebrity atheists around
us yeah and
you know part of what i'm at least
dealing with and i
think you probably are too if i read the
comments on your videos correctly
we're dealing with a lot of people
who i had a conversation with poe the
person from the uk
and and they're they're sort of in the
there's some in the
reiki camp is sort of that they're a
little
more comfortable with the woo um
[Music]
and the new ageish stuff and the
circling
and you know the reiki camp is over
there but there's still another
element over over here who are the
engineers
and you know verveiki just feels a
little scary
um and they they're saying boy i really
need something in my
life like a church but
you know and and and so pastorally i'm
trying to figure out
and and in some ways the discord server
for me i just did a couple of
conversations with a guy named topher
from from toronto
people are working through this stuff
and
um and like topher's topher was
that's sort of where my estuary concept
has has come in because
people are working through this stuff
and they need a space to
they need a they need a space where they
can play with things
and have permission to play with things
and that's always a dangerous space for
people to be in
but it's usually a necessary space for
people to
grow yeah and i think
but i think that that's it and i think
that that's the best that the online
thing can offer us
and it's important to see that we you
know it's a place where
change can it's a place where
exploration and transformation can
happen
you know because it is it is a safe it's
like it's a little it's
it's kind of this exploration but kind
of safe exploration because you're just
sitting at home right
you're on a screen and you're listening
to things you're watching things and so
i think that that's a great
it's a great thing if you can offer that
to people and the opportunity to
to discuss in a safe like a not
safe in the in the kind of safe space
idea but in a
with people that they feel are are at
least asking similar questions
and you know and so i think that that's
i think that's great like i dropped into
the
to the bridges uh meaning uh to oh
as as like this boomer that doesn't know
how discord works and i'd like drop into
conversations and if you were like
jonathan is here
but then my mic wasn't on and then i i
saw like they were just thought i was
just and it was just weird but
like i've seen some great some just some
great discussion and
and uh and a lot of people getting
involved and helping each other and
giving people giving each other advice
and uh and so it's a
i think it's a i think that it can it
really can
nudge people to in the right direction
that's for sure but like you said there
are
we just need to i think we need to be
careful not to think that
not to let it become like a new religion
or a new
or or uh you know a new centralized
thing that that uh
but but that's yeah i think that i think
at least i trust you like i don't think
you're gonna i don't i don't think
you're gonna
next time i talk to you you're gonna be
wearing a new funny hat with like uh
with some kind of liturgical clothing
and then you'll be
archbishop paul of the the church of
bridges or something
you know like i just it's not possible i
i mean who knows but i don't see it
so so i think we're fine i think you you
shouldn't worry too much about that
stuff
well what do you what do you want to do
with the symbolic world i mean this has
it's it's a blog it's your videos
um you've got a facebook group where you
have discussions
i mean where where do you want this
thing to go so to me what i
see is i see this as a like a training
ground
and so what i see what i notice is i see
people who watch my videos and
are starting to think in terms of
symbolic symbolic thinking
and so they they all they are these
people that are thinking that way that
have the capacity to do so
i see it that they need to kind of play
with it and experiment and
and test it against other people and so
the facebook group seems to be doing
that and it's
it's doing it without me like i don't
even run that you know it's
it's being run by jacob russell and and
a few other people
and and so i can see people propose
symbolic ideas and then
then you have people adding and testing
and
wondering about what they're saying um
and so that's what i see and the same
with the blog
is i want to it's like it's like a
training ground for symbolic thinkers
that i hope will then go back into their
own
communities and produce fruits
and and help others embody it
also create stories a mix of
understanding and production
like having artists create new things
you know and also being sensitive to the
the propaganda and culture and how you
know they use symbolic
they use they they kind of distort
symbolic language to to
to influence society um so that's what i
see
i really do see it that way as a as a
as a kind of little little army like a
little army of symbolists that
will then go back into their own world
and have effect
a little army of symbolism little army
of symbolism
how do you feel about being a leader i
really don't feel like a leader
i i wish i i don't i think that i i've
actually
maybe to the dismay of some i've
actually kind of not been too involved
on the on the on the facebook group
like i'll like things you know and i'll
write a few comments but i
i i try not to be too involved just
because i really don't want people to
follow me because i feel like it just
doesn't make any sense
like i'm online for goodness sake like
you don't know me if people don't know
me people can't see all my
my foibles and my problems and
everything so i really don't
uh i really don't i don't
i really don't see it that way so
hopefully i can
point people back to their own
authorities like in the church something
like that
yeah yeah yeah well good
uh we've you've been gone you are a
leader though
and is that what you think no you are
that's um but it's
you know this this gets into my
questions about this whole space
and about what youtube is and about what
can be accomplished in a facebook group
or on a discord server
and about the this is this is
two-dimensional
and if people i i
keep trying to emphasize this
with people that nothing too dimensional
is real enough
and and so
you might participate in a in
on a discord server in a facebook group
and you might watch
you might watch a youtube channel and
you might grow from
i certainly want that but it does have
to
manifest in three dimensions in time
in locality and
any we
yeah we we have to we have to come to
terms with
the limitations of this medium so that
we really resist the distortions it
creates
yeah oh i think you're right i think
it's a good call
for all of us people watching and then
us as well both you and i
to be attentive to that and to be
careful it's a it's definitely a
minefield because
you have to be honest like if i when i
if i receive comments of people
thanking me for what i'm doing it's like
that's that man that goes straight
right up to up right up to the to the
ego and so it's
it's a dangerous it's always like a
dangerous situation
and uh so hopefully god protects us from
from uh from pride in that
in that moment but uh yeah but i think
that the
like i said the the the fact that i'm
seeing people kind of take it on
take on their own like i love to see
what jp
maxwell's doing i think that he's just
such a great character coming up like
we've had some wonderful people writing
for the blog recently that i think
you know there's a for someone who's
named richard rowland who wrote
an article about saint dionysus the
areopagite well he's now
like becoming the co-host of the amon
sewell podcast which is about tolkien
and
orthodoxy and so it's like seeing these
people kind of move out
and you know not like they're only
but they were in this discussion about
symbolism and then starting to kind of
apply it in other fields and and uh
that's what excites me more than
anything you know and so that's what i
hope to see
you know i i starting the church of the
church of jonathan or something
it's the pejorian church the pejoey and
the pashoens
[Laughter]
it's good that that doesn't roll off the
tongue huh it's actually probably pretty
good for joey and it doesn't sound right
well it's but it is a tale of warning
because
both luther and calvin would have been
horrified
by the fact that there are religious
traditions named after
them you know there should not be
lutherans there should not be
calvinists and the apostle paul makes
that clear in the book of corinthians
yeah and but but that is that is a
that is a natural thing that is the
natural way we use
labels but um i don't know i
i feel the same way i look at the
discord server and
i look at job and jeff
and luke and sherry and andrea
and i see leaders that you cannot
you cannot have a healthy community
without leaders who
who manifest usually different things in
the community
but around which the community coheres
and when things start
going off to the side they're the ones
who who pull it back say no we're not
going to do that we're going to do this
we're not going to talk that way we're
going to talk this way and
and that you know then the community
starts to cohere
and grow and to become a place where
a place where people can can change and
be
formed by christ and what's what's so
interesting is is that
you know job job you can watch job's
conversion with my conversations with
him over time you can see
elements of it and and and none of us
are fully formed
but the formation
is happening and the
the the witness to the former
is manifest in the forming process
and we're watching that happen and
that's tremendously exciting
so yeah yeah
well good it's a good note to to end and
i
i i really i really enjoy our
conversations and for sure i really feel
like we're
we're on similar paths and we're kind of
we can learn from each other as well
i've been spending more time on your
channel
especially in the past month or so and
so and so i i think we need to continue
our our ongoing discussions i agree
i agree and and again i i it sounds
terribly fanboyish but
i i i do think
well let me say it this way um
i've been watching this migration
in my own denomination in church
planters
for a while long before the jordan
peterson thing or long before i knew
your name
and i'm i'm seeing
so so this isn't just
idiosyncratic jonathan pajot who somehow
you know caught a wave this is this is
this is a bigger movement by
the spirit in the world that
we are you know we we are participating
in
and but your work has has been
tremendously helpful to me
to um to
sort of get beyond a dual substance
model
into a vision which is
i think is which is more unifying and i
think actually more biblical
so i um keep doing what you're doing
because it's uh
it's i think it's really important stuff
so well thanks for the encouragement
paul and uh enjoy
i hope you're moved to the to the old
house goes well
yeah this is it people i this is this
this sunday i'm moving i'm moving on
sunday
into my house that was flooded a year
and a half ago and so
we're really excited about that and uh
yeah i'm
that's pretty much all i can think about
right now it's very difficult to think
about anything else
well and i i hope covid relents and
maybe september 2021
i can meet you in thunder bay that'd be
awesome i would love that happens so
yeah
all right jonathan it's great to talk to
you take care bye-bye